[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
workflows can orchestrate and automate
your api driven workflows
workflows is a fully managed service
that gives you the power to integrate
tasks
microservices and apis reliable
execution lets you create dependable
workflows that can automate complex
processes
across any google cloud products or http
based apis
since it's fully serverless you can
focus on the logic and not worry about
the infrastructure
or how to scale built-in error handling
and retry policies give you a highly
reliable and resilient architecture
dashboards give you true visibility into
what's happening
and when getting started is easy
using the console or the command line
you can define your workflow as a simple
yaml or json file
to spell out which services and apis you
want to include
each service can also pass information
to the next
letting you build custom workflows that
match the business logic you need
and since it's all serverless you only
pay for what you need
scaling down to zero during slow times
let's look at an example use case
maybe you have a website called beyond
tree a one stop shop for vegan dog
treats
you might decide to create a workflow to
fulfill orders for specific dog treats
a new order kicks off the workflow first
we check cloud firestore to see if we
have enough inventory
if we do we update the inventory in the
database
then a cloud run app fulfills the
request and calls a third party email
api
to send the customer an order
confirmation
if there isn't inventory the workflow
can check once per day
until the item is back in stock so
next time you're looking to automate
your application services take a minute
to look at workflows
to learn more check out
[Music]
cloud.google.comworkflows
you